les déportés 33 ans après les souvenirs
ou
l'oubli Londres marche contre les
racistes Italie 2000 radio 66
télévisions le monopole éclaté pour qui
pour quoi faire une enquête d'édard Lore
à la fin de cette
édition bonsoir et avant de développer
tous ces titres je vous propose de jeter
un petit coup d'œil vers le ciel vers la
météo pour demain lundi pour la fin donc
de ce long weekend de 3 jours et c'est
pas très brillant demain matin sur la
plupart des régions nuag et pluie un peu
partout sauf sur le nord-est du pays et
la Bretagne où il y aura de belles
éclaircis en revanche dans l'après-midi
la séparation sera plus nette le mauvais
temps va se localiser sur la moitié
sud-est de la France quelques giboulé
encore sur le nord-ouest mais tout de
même de belles
éclaircies revenons maintenant au grand
titre de ce journal avec un événement
qui bien loin évidemment de la couleur
du temps et de ces jours de détente il
s'agit de la journée nationale de la
déportation aviez-vous vu les affiches
par exemple alors plusieurs cérémonies
commémoratives ont eu lieu aujourd'hui à
Paris devant le mémorial des martyres à
l'Arc de Triomphe et au montvalérien des
dépôts de gerbes en présence de Monsieur
Plantier secrétaire d'État aux anciens
combattants et de nombreux résistants et
déportés les déportés qui se souviennent
madame René Brown par exemple elle était
résistante et en août 1944 elle a été
arrêtée les garçons de son groupe ont
été fusillé les Allemands l'ont emmené
vers l'Allemagne elle a 23 ans
lorsqu'elle arrive à
Ravensbruck quand les portes de
ravensbru se sont ouvertes
pour nous faire pénétrer dans le camp
alors là ça a été l'horreur l'horreur
parce que je me souviens très bien par
exemple d'un groupe de de prisonnière
qui avait le Tyfus qui nous regardait
sans nous voir avec des yeux immenses il
y avait plus que les yeux dans le visage
c'est c'était c'était vraiment affreux
et là là encore je ne pense pas avoir
échangé avec des camarades des propos
dans lesquels la crainte de devenir
comme ça se est pas tout de suite ça a
été l'horreur l'horreur de la découverte
c'était c'était affreux tous les jours
des tous les jours des des femmes et des
très jeunes femmes et même des enfants
qui mourent puisqueà l'époque il y avait
des enfants de zigane d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui nombreux qui ont été
exterminés aujourd'hui la nuit est-ce
que des fois ces souvenirs reviennent à
oui oui oui mais sous des pas toujours
le concentration l'arrestation aussi ça
m'est arrivé dernièrement je au cours de
la préparation cette manifestation ation
de Cologne bien sûr on a été amené à
reparler un peu plus un peu plus que
d'habitude et dans la nuit je me suis
réveillée en grillant j'étais en train
de courir dans une rue qui était bordée
de chaque côté de d'un mur on me courait
après et vraiment je pouvais ni tourner
à gauche ni à droite c'était affreux à
on allait me prendre on allait me
prendre c'était épouvantable et même le
camp ça m'arrive aussi encore lors ce
que vous voyez pardon parce que parce
que cela fait naître une
hypersensibilité devant
devant la souffrance devant une pas pas
une lâcheté mais une hypersensibilité
c'est-à-dire que c'est c'est très
difficilement supportable par nous de
savoir que dans des pays des enfants
meurent ou bien que l'on torture ça
c'est affreux c'est c'est même
impensable pour nous que ça puisse
encore exister aujourd'hui ça nous
vraiment ça nous ça nous peine beaucoup
parce qu'on est là impuissant encore on
est impuissant au quatre coins du monde
on torture des des femmes des enfants
des hommes on les termine et donc ça a
changé votre vie jusqu' aujourd'hui ah
oui vous voyez les choses autrement très
certainement que peut-être je ne me
pencherai peut-être pas autant sur les
problèmes dont je viens de parler
peut-être si je n'avais pas vécu ça
c'est possible est-ce que votre vie de
tous les jours s'en trouve changée
oui par cette par
cette les les déportés sont souvent des
gens angoissés aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
oui c'est vrai très très souvent c'est
c'est vraiment une séquelle d'ailleurs
l'angoisse vous savez est-ce que vous
avez de la haine encore pas du tout pas
du tout
non pensez-vous que des histoires comme
la vôtre lorsqu'elles sont racontées aux
jeunes elles puissent servir d'exemple
encore et d'exemple et et
d'avertissement et surtout
d'avertissement et je pense j'affirme
même là je peux me permettre de dire au
nom de tous les déportés que si on se
taisait aujourd'hui on ne mériterait pas
d'être
revenu pas de haine est-ce possible
lorsqu'on a vécu ce qui paraissait
impensable est-ce possible surtout
lorsque les années passantes des jeunes
générations ne connaissent de cet hreur
que des récits ou des films qui gâchent
la quiétude du quotidien avez-vous
remarqué que ces gens qui en sont
revenus ont tendance souvent à se
refermer en eux-mêmes comme s'ils ne
voulaient plus parler de peur de ne
rencontrer d'apercevoir sur les autres
visages sinon l'indifférence du moins la
lassitude le devoir de témoigner
disait-elle cette rescapé c'est vrai
puisque'au milieu même de ce weekend
tranquille le jour où l'on voudrait ne
pouvoir ne penser à rien se descendre un
germe se réveille et se multiplie deci
de là dans le monde les crocodiles
l'Ouganda les stades du Chili les
goulaces de l'Est et aussi par exemple à
Scotti près de Chicago là-bas près de ce
de buckenvald en plus de leurs souvenirs
vont maintenant voir défiler devant eux
de nouveaux jeunes nazis avec la vieille
croix
GAM le téléphone a sonné c'était une
bande enregistrée et la voix disait ce
que Hitler n'a pas terminé pendant la
guerre nous allons le faire avec les
Juifs d'Amérique cela s'est passé hier
soir lundi 17 avril 1978 aux
États-Unis et dans un autre quartier de
Chicago une conférence de presse
avez-vous regardé Holocaust sur NBC oui
je l'ai
vu c'est l'histoire de deux familles
histoire de terreur de d'amour c'est
seulement une histoire mais une histoire
qui s'est vraiment
passé et pendant 4 soirées et 9h
d'émission la chaîne NBC a fait
découvrir aux Américains l'histoire des
camps de concentration et
d'extermination 120 millions de
téléspectateurs ont regardé
holocausteour
chicagooki le passé et le présent
aujourd'hui se sont trouvé
rassemblés nous ne vivons pas ici parce
que c'est Sky nous avons perdu nos
familles et ici nous avons retrouvé une
autre
famille c'est sans doute pourquoi il y a
autant de survivants desamp ici à qui
veulent vivre ensemble
en arrivant au États-Unis enant nos
enfants nous pensions que des choses
comme ça ne se reproduir
plus ici à Chicago il y a partti na qui
veut organiser une marche dans notre
village pour Mo revir la
croix 700 habitants est un village ses
habitants le plus grand village de
survivant des camps ils sont 7000 res
d'z bergenbson
trea mais à 10 km de leur maison dans un
quartier pauvre de Chicago voici ce que
l'on peut
voir
c'est vrai qu'on fait de la publicité au
naz mais aujourd'hui la publicité est
pour nous alors que pendant des années
les gens nous interrogai sur les camp
sur l'holocaust sur la croix
gamé vous savez il y avait beaucoup des
sondages ici on souvient pas le nom na
on a demandé qu'est-ce que ça je sais
pas
le parti nazi pourtant existe et à
pignon sur rue à Chicago avec son chef
Frank cing et un millier de sympathisant
pour la ville 100000 sur l'ensemble des
États-Unis donnant ici une conférence de
presse le 19 avril pour l'anniversaire
de la naissance de Hitler ses objectifs
préserver la race blanche et combattre
les noirs et les Juifs affirmant par
exemple que la France a connu sa période
la plus florissante entre 1940 et 194
nous voulons marcher dans ce coqui parce
que c'est notre droit nous voulons faire
ce qui est permis à toutes les minorités
de ce pays ce qui est permis au noirs
aux
homosexuels peut-on malgré le premier
amendement de la Constitution qui permet
à chacun des citoyens des États-Unis
d'exprimer ses opinions peut-on
autoriser
toutes les inititives et les actions du
parti naz il
estut- Dansette
effort les nazis ont réussi d'avoir
davantage de
publicité
mais c'est la vie dans une démocratie et
nous devons
l'accepter les nazis de veulent donc
dans un geste de provocation défiler
dans ceoky alors que non seulement scoki
mais les États-Unis viennent de recevoir
comme un choc les images et l'histoire
des camps de la mort et chacun de se
poser la question au nom de la liberté
de ce fameux premier amendement peut-on
tout autoriser et pour les habitants de
scoki c'est le retour de la psychose
avec cette phrase
terrible nous résisterons
résister le mot semble anachronique
sorti du temps alors que des réunion ont
lieu dans tout le pays pour y parler de
l'atrocité des camps le film Holocaust a
surpris les États-Unis et l'histoire de
skoky pose une question à laquelle la
Cour suprême devra répondre une nation
qui garantit les libertés peut-elle
autoriser les Américains portant
uniforme nazi à défiler sous les
fenêtres des rescapés d'Auschwitz
dans l'actualité encore il y a ces
quelques télégrammes des députés
socialistes vont rencontrer le président
de la République le 11 mai prochain
Gaston de fer conduira la délégation Val
cardestin les a en effet invité pour
parler des problèmes de désarmement et
de sécurité quelques jours plus tard
vous le savez le chef de l'État ira aux
Nations Unies présenter un plan français
de désarmement Afghanistan le coup
d'État militaire qui a renversé le
prince Daoud aurait fait plusieurs
centaines de victimes exécuté par les
nouveaux maîtres du pays la République
démocratique d'Afghanistan c'est le
nouveau nom du pays a donc maintenant un
nouveau chef de l'État il s'appelle
monsieur
Taraki à l'heure du 3e retrait israélien
du Sud-Liban monsieur bin le Premier
ministre israélien vient d'arriver aux
États-Unis où elle doit participer aux
cérémonies du 30e anniversaire de l'État
d'Israël une rencontre Carter béin est
prévue pour demain lundi notez en
passant que les États-Unis viennent de
passer à l'heure d'été ils sont à gmt4
maintenant à New York c'estàdire qu'en
clair il y a 6h de différence avec la
France l'enlèvement d'Aldo Moro il se
confirme que le président de la
démocratie chrétienne a bien envoyé
récemment près d'une dizaine de lettres
à ses amis politiques à sa famille mais
également au numéro 1 du Parti
socialiste italien il s'étonne ce numéro
1 du Parti socialiste italien du contenu
de cette lettre presque irréelle
monsieur Morau parle comme si tout était
déjà fini pour lui comme s'il avait déjà
rejoint le paradis à l'étranger encore
en image cette fois d'autres
informations et en premier les
explosions qui ont eu lieu en Italie la
nuit dernière
Italie si attentats contre les
établissements Alpa Romeo à Padou un
magasin d'exposition de véhicules et les
locaux de la société incendiés par des
inconnus à Rome qu magasins Alpa Romeo
plastiqués dans les de ville les
attentats ont été revendiqués par des
équipes ouvrières armé apparemment rien
à voir avec l'affaire Morau
l'organisation justifie ses attentats
pour protester contre les heures
supplémentaires et un récent accord
entre syndicat et direction
Madrid fusion des deux partis
socialistes espagnols François mitéran
pour le Parti socialiste français Mario
soirz Premier ministre portugais et
beino Craxi du PS italien parmi les
personnalités présentes aujourd'hui à
Madrid le Parti socialiste populaire le
PSP du professeur Enrico tiiernier
galban s'est officiellement intégré au
Parti socialiste ouvrier espagnol le PSE
de felppe gzalz le parti né de
l'intégration conservera l'appellation
PSOE
Londres manifestation contre l'extrême
droite 50000 britanniques des jeunes
pour la plupart se sont réunis
aujourd'hui à Trafalgar Square pour une
marche de protestation contre le Front
national la marche s'est déroulée dans
le calme au rythme de plusieurs
orchestres juguchés sur des
camions le cortège long de plusieurs
kilomètres a traversé le centre de
Londres encadré par la présence ffec de
police
réduit Paris enfin manifestation pour le
3e anniversaire de la chute de saon 2 à
3000 vietnamiens venus de toute la
France mais aussi d'Europe ont
manifester pour réclamer le respect des
droits de l'homme au Vietnam les
manifestants pour la plupart des
réfugiés politiques souhaitent que les
pays du monde entier prennent en
considération leur doléan notamment la
libération des prisonniers politiques
des religieux
bien c'est donc l'heure maintenant de
notre dossier radio et télévision en
Italie en deux mots on peit dire que
l'Italie c'est l'Amérique aujourd'hui
chez notre voisin en effet on retrouve
66 chaînes de télévision et près de 2000
stations de radio il y a peu de temps
encore vous le savez l'Italie c'était
comme en France c'estàd qu'il y avait le
monopole et puis peu à peu décision des
députés d'abord des juges ensuite le
monopole a éclaté alors c'est une
question intéressante est par
pour nous c'est pourquiard est allé
faire une enquête en Italie en se posant
d'abord de questions la fin du monopole
oui mais pour qui et pour quoi
faire le
reportageainant nale sur le canal 21 un
dimanche après-midi en
direct an la raille a perdu 30 % de ses
téléspectateurs au profit de la station
locale privée Canal
21 juillet 1976 sur plainte déposée par
un particulier la Cour constitutionnelle
décrète que le monopole des onde
n'appartient plus à la puissante radio
télévision d'État la rail rien pourtant
n'ébranle cette énorme machine le
pouvoir politique se partage les deux
chaînes de télévision depuis le conseil
d'administration jusqu'aux équipes de
reportage la deè chaîne est à gauche
mélange de socialiste et
communistes son journal est à 19h45
elle interprète à sa façon les
événements qui ont secoué l'Italie
pendant les 6 mois de
crise véritable institution qu'elle
mérite d'être parfaitement clair pour
les téléspectateurs italiens la première
chaîne elle diffuse son grand journal à
20h mais cette fois l'interprétation du
même événement est démocrate
chrétienne devenu légal depuis 76 les
premières attaques contre le monopole de
la raille remontent en fait à 5 ans et
ce sont les radioamateurs qui ont
déclenché la guerre la plus connue sans
doute aujourd'hui radio Sita Futura un
grenier au sommet d'un immeuble une
antenne sur le toit et un poste
émetteur radio cita Futura dans la
pagaille et l'anarchie émet pratiquement
24 he sur 24 chacun peut entrer ici y
exprimer une opinion de préférence
d'extrême gauche ou entamer un débat qui
peut duré toute la
nuit on en compte près de 2000 en Italie
120 à Rome le plus souvent des radios de
quartier et celles qui étaient à
l'origine des radios pirates avec à leur
tête Renzo Rossellini sont devenu
aujourd'hui des radios libres il y a des
gens qui nous écoutent
pour la liberté d'expression qu'il y a
dans cette radio en Italie le langage
officiel de la radio de la télévision
est très stéréotypé très convin inelle
et là c'est un langage libre c'est le
langage de tous les jours c'est le
langage des gens du bon sens ou le
langage euh avec lesquels les masses les
gens s'expriment non donc ça c'était
déjà un choc moi je pense que la
première fois que quelqu'un a ouvert une
radio et en cherchant une une station à
écouter une radio libre il il a eu
sement un choc non puisque c'était une
moyen d'expression complètement
différent comment peut-on expliquer
cette prolifération des radios
ces radios ont été inventé à une
certaine époque de mass media en Italie
justement pour couvrir un espace je
m'explique ils veulent couvrir l'espace
des structures sociologiques qui sont
entre les deux grands système d'échange
en Italie qui sont la famille d'une part
et l'état de l'autre l'État qui est
inaccessible et avec lequel on peut pas
dialoguer et la famille au contraire
avec lesquel on échange des des des des
problèmes qui sont des problèmes qui
restent limités à à la dimension
familiale quant à la télévision nous
sommes toujours plein d'admiration
devant les Américains qui ont à leur
disposition 9 ou 10 chaînes de
télévision et bien ici à Rome les
Italiens ont fait beaucoup mieux d'abord
ils reçoivent Antenne
2 et puis les deux chaînes de la raille
et une soixantaine de chaînes
privées
il y a ceux enfin qui n'ont pas encore
la possibilité technique d'émettre des
programmes complets et qui diffusent
tout simplement une mire 24h sur 24 pour
éviter que d'autres n'occupent le même
canal et les télévisions vous
l'expliquez la même façon la télévision
il faut tenir compte le succès de la
télévision en Italie est dû au fait de
l'engouement des Italiens pour l'image
vous savez très bien que la civilisation
italienne à l'égard d'autrre
civilisation plus nordique est une
civilisation qui tient compte de la
parole évidemment mais tient compte
surtout de l'image et quand je dis image
tenir compte du geste tenir compte de
l'expression et ce il suffit de
réfléchir un peu au film italien pour
pour signifier ce que ça veut dire image
image c'est pas seulement l'image fixe
mais c'est le geste le comportement
c'est l'expression et cetera et alors
les Italiens sont très sensibles aux
argument transmis par ce véhicule et
donc les succès de télévision et en
parti accès aussi à cet
engouement un hôtel particulier dans le
quartier le plus riche de Rome et l'une
des 66 chaînes de télévision téoma 56
la Villa appartient à un architecte on y
a posé les metteur sur le toit et
installer un studio dans la
cave per noi siamo rovinati
gen ici pas de publicité pas de film
Toma 56 n qu'en direct avec un téléphone
l'animateur un psychat professeur à
l'Université de Rome le principe de
l'émission estle on lance thème de
discussion et ch peut appeler le studio
pour exprimer à l'antenne ce qu'il
ressent pas de politique téoma 56 se dit
volontiers une télévision d'intellectuel
de gauche se défend d'être une
télévision de classe se veut une
télévision d'élite pourvu qu'avec
l'élite on inclut aussi la classe
ouvrière dans la banlieue de Rome à une
dizaine de kilomètres du centre de la
capitale une autre des 66 chaînes uomo
TV la télévision de l'homme créé en
octobre 77 avec une quinzaine de
personnes uomo TV émet 3 ou 4 heures par
jour sans aucune publicité le tout
supervisé par un ancien directeur de la
raille et financé par quelques grosses
fortunes italienes comme d'autres
s'achèteraiit un
jouet B il a nous avons des actionnaires
qui sont pas
de des des des rois soleil mais qui m
don l'argent
pour il faut il faut être très riche
pour pour investir dans quelque chose
qui ne rapporte pas du tout je crois
alors j'espère j'espère quelqu'un soit
riche dernier gadget en date sur
la ciao àpr laom
can
ilil Eco il filmedia sera la morte
dellocchio
cristalle la Lada
art dites-moi Jean Jean c'est votre vrai
prénom oui je vois dans une revue de
télévision que vous êtes la spécialiste
française de l'antiprésentation ça veut
dire quoi l'antiprésentation
l'antiprésentation ça veut dire que j'ai
rien du tout d'une présentatrice
c'està-dire que je me Gour enfin je me
trompe toujours dans les programmes je
me trompe toujours dans le titre dans le
titre du film enfin j'ai rien du tout
d'une présentatrice et puis après je
fais toujours mes mes grimace et tout ça
alors qu'une présentatrice normalement
elle doit être très sérieuse vous
travaillez ici parce que vous êtes
française ou non non pas du tout
absolument
pas enfin la plus grosse des stations de
télévision privée JBR installé purement
et simplement dans les sous-sols d'un
grand hôtel sur les hauteurs de
Rome
Giovanni del piano PDG d'une chaîne de
grand magasin s'est offert pour 2
milliards de les ce dont il rêvait
depuis toujours mais en bon commerçant
il s'agit cette fois de rentabiliser
l'affaire alors à JBR tout est fait pour
et par le téléspectateur une fois par
semaine les studios sont transformés en
un marché opus l'émission commence à 19h
les enchères se font par
téléphone JBR éet ainsi 24 he sur 24
mais son grand succès vient sans doute
des programmes de nuit trois films le
plus souvent pornographique à 2h 4h et 6
du
matin non inter
non pornogph mais c'est pas la culture
ça
non notte
la l' notte l'
la fait l'am et dans la jourée fait la
culture est-ce que c'est votre
définition
h la téision spettac c'est un spectac
et la pornographie voilà là il s'agit
aussi d'un fait sociologique intéressant
l'Italie comme comme tous les pays
catholiques voyez ce qui s'est passé en
Espagne maintenant après actuellement
après la fin de la dictature de Franco
il y a une sorte de contreéaction qui se
fait contre des tabou qui avaient
pendant des longues années imposé
peut-être une pluderie excessive il y a
des excès certainement dans l'emploi de
ce type de film il y a un espace qui est
occupé en partie par le cinéma
pornographique aussi dans les salles de
cinéma soit en Italie qu'en Espagne
évidemment la télévision ressent un peu
cette sorte de mauvaise tendance je
considère tout ça comme pernicieux un
certain point de vue si ça devait
continuer ou se manifester avec excès
d'autre part un fait assez positif parce
qu'il s'agit de se libérer de beaucoup
de tabou qui étaient totalement
inutile tous les soirs à minuit à Naple
comme à Rome les émissions de télévision
sont réservées aux adultes film interdit
je scriptise ou tout simplement cela
arrive émission carrément
pornographique pour des téléspectateurs
italiens étonnés au début presque
habitué
aujourd'hui le gouvernement italien
étudie un projet qui devrait permettre
non pas d'interdire mais de limiter
cette hémorragie sur les ondes
hémorragie qui aura au moins un mérite
si les critères de qualité ne sont que
rarement respectés celui d'apporter aux
Italiens de nouveaux modes de
communication et un choix un choix que
beaucoup d'autres pays pourrai bien leur
envier voilà pour être complet il me
faut encore vous donner les résultats du
tiercé Jean-Michel vous pouvez le mettre
sur les écrans voilà c'est 2 3 et 7
malheureusement comme disait Robert chat
tout à l'heure je n'ai pas encore les
les rapports de ce tierc je pense qu'
Claude qui vous présentera la dernière
édition du journal vers 22h50 qui
travaille déjà d'ailleurs aura les
rapports de ce tiercé voilà je vous
retrouverai demain soir avec plaisir
pour vous présenter l'édition de 20h du
journal je vous souhaite au nom de toute
l'équipe qui m'a aidé à préparer
celui-ci une très belle soirée sur
Antenne
a